[Musik]
fliegen kann
wir bringen in dieser woche gibt es
einen ganz ungewöhnlichen film neu im
kino nämlich bild von nicolette krebitz
das ist ein deutscher film und er ist
wirklich das wildeste was ich in letzter
zeit gesehen habe
es geht um eine frau die sich in einen
wolf beliebt und zwar das in keiner
weise mit der vor gericht sondern
vollständig wörtlich zu nehmen
seine junge frau gespielt mit wirklich
höchstem risiko und großer radikalität
als junge frau die ihn an
plattenbau irgendwo unbestimmt im osten
deutschlands lebt ich vermute ich glaube
es
von halle gedreht der trostlose gegend
und in eine firma als fachfrau arbeitet
was sie aber deutlich unter vorhalt
eines tages
für alle
es geht in diesem film um eine
verwilderung das heißt das ist nicht
immer gold
die hat nicht so zahm wird für diese
nach hause die jungs auch die zuletzt
gebildeten mit diesen hier zusammen zu
können will ich stamme das spielt sie
eine frau die uns mit einer großen
radikalität und einem mut der wirklich
beachtlich ist denn im gegensatz zum
beispiel zu leonardo dicaprio der ja
kürzlich einen oscar dafür gewonnen habe
dass er sich mit einem bär eingelassen
hat der vollständig aus pixeln bestand
ist dieser wald ein echter wölfe lassen
wie jack an themen und insofern ist das
teil dieser schauspielerischen leistung
das gerät spannung darauf ist hinbekommt
eine intimität mir gesehen hier spürbar
und sichtbar zu machen die wirklich
erstaunlich
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich uns frühstück
guck mal dass ein hühnerei kennst du
doch bestimmt es ist ganz deutlich
also ich es sage ja ohne schal frauen
was eigentlich nur bedeutet das ja uns
einen blick auf die welt auf gemeint
schnell auf die türe zeit geben die
übliche ich jetzt außerdem gerne ketchup
datiert das sind eigentlich tomaten und
gewürze aber kaputt geht schneller
liebsten würde ich dazu ja cola trennten
es geht wirklich zu weit
[Musik]